hi there steve kaufman here uh talking
to you again
about my great passion which is language
learning
um
if you enjoy these videos um please
subscribe
uh i do feel strongly that anyone can
learn languages
one foreign language several foreign
languages and i try to encourage people
to to do so and provide some
advice from my own experience
so today i want to talk about the idea
that
with a relatively limited vocabulary we
can actually
communicate quite effectively in in a
language in a foreign language
um
you know it is known that a relatively
small number of words
say a thousand words will account for
70
depending on you know the context 60 70
75 percent of any given
language content so if we just learn
those 1000 words uh we can then uh do
quite well in the language that's the
theory
i have never found that to be the case
okay so up front i'll give you the
conclusion
not true
uh for a variety of reasons
first of all
i just the reason i'm
you know wanting to talk about this is
because i was noticing that in my arabic
now i have 1100 known words the way we
count words at link
now granted uh you know in arabic
there's different forms of verbs and
nouns and they tack the and onto
nouns and so
you know this number in terms of word
families would be quite a bit lower
so it's not totally indicative but it's
a beginning of an indication of just how
much you can cover with a limited
vocabulary so
i have 1100 known words
probably it's a bit higher but let's say
it's 1100 known words
as identified by link by the system
so if i open a new lesson
in the many stories series we have 60
many stories in arabic the same many
stories that i used for greek and i love
them they're addictive they cover
mostly the most common vocabulary in
particular the most common verbs which i
think is very important so it's not you
know real authentic content
but
and there's a lot of repetition in them
but if i open a news story
even though i know 1100 words
typically there's 35 to 40 percent
unknown words in those lessons unknown
to me
unknown to me means i haven't come
across them before in our system
if i open a lesson from let's learn
arabic which is still material that is
designed for learners but it's a little
more difficult
and it's a different series so a
different vocabulary there i'm looking
at 50 unknown words
if i open
because that link we have this news feed
so i can get you know uh articles from
huffington post in arabic or whatever
happens to feed into my feed
there there's 60 unknown words so i have
1100 known words but these
lessons either you know learner material
showing me 40 unknown words
intermediate level material 50 unknown
words news articles 60
unknown words in other words in other
words
having 1100 known words doesn't enable
me
to understand these articles
there are still lots of words that i
don't know
and you know it's true for example
typically in the sort of beginner books
where they promise that you will master
this language
and they take you to you know the
customs and the doctor and the bank and
therefore now you know this vocabulary
it doesn't work that way because even if
you think you know
a thousand words
when you need them you probably won't
remember them or there's a good chance
you know how many times
have i looked i need to know the word
for such and such because i don't know
i'm going to the store to buy this
uh two problems with that probably i
will forget the word by the time i get
to the store it's happened to me so
often
or
because we have no way of anticipating
what that person in the store is going
to say what words they're going to use
um
that word may not even the words that i
think i now have mastered that are going
to enable me to navigate this instant
this situation
in fact there might be a whole new range
of words that come come up so
the conclusion is
the idea that you can somehow focus in
on a small number of words and then be
comfortable in the language is simply
not true
beyond that because
the best way to get used to a language
is to do a lot of listening and reading
you can't stay forever with
content that only has these you know
most frequent 1000 words you have to get
into other words
and
the less frequent words of course they
appear less frequently so they're more
difficult to learn and therefore you
have to consume massive quantities of
material before these words sink in but
as you are pursuing
this is my i always sort of make
reference to this sort of
you know
dog races where the dogs chase the
mechanical rabbit
as i am chasing
these new words and trying to increase
my vocabulary on link at the same time
i'm going over again and again and again
the words that i already know the
structures that i have already met i'm
becoming familiar with the language so
that
those even the high frequency words i'm
not learning them as a deliberate task
with lists
i am absorbing them naturally so that
they become a comfortable part of me and
that's one of the reasons by the way
that i really recommend using our many
stories we have them in a variety of
languages
linked because
they're good to get started in a
language i use them for greek i'm using
them for arabic
but i want to go back and do russian in
many stories and and check many stories
because
it's an opportunity to go over some of
the basic structures and the basic
vocabulary because there's always things
that slip all these things that we lose
and that's why we need to have this
massive exposure and you can't just go
in there and try to isolate
a small number of very high frequency
words and hope to achieve anything close
to
fluency or even
any level of comfort in the language so
there you have it i look forward to your
comments bye for now
[Music]
you